[Music]
which came first
the chicken
or the egg there's nothing wrong with
the naked human body and our genitals
even the mathematics breaks down the
equations break down so they can't
penetrate beyond that how to emancipate
ourselves from ideology to change not so
much our mind but our actual social
threats and make hopefully the world a
little bit of a better place
[Music]
are we just victims to hollywood fantasy
anyone want to does anyone want to jump
in with them it's funny
it's called lost in the matrix because
the matrix is actually not like the
simulation hypothesis at all right so
the the the whole premise of the matrix
and i'm hoping the fourth instantiation
of it is non-shit i mean
that is a bold statement
um you know the premise of the matrix is
they're real brains that are in some
some sort of factory farm environment
being being milked for their for their
power and really the experience that
people like neo and all the characters
in the matrix have is due it's more the
brain in the vat experiment that their
brain activity has been manipulated in
particular
ways so that they have this experience
of the real
world that's a very very different claim
to the fact that the claim that the
universe is in fact a computer
simulation and we are all characters
within that computer simulation i love
the first movie but it's a really
horrible premise
human human brains generate so little
power that these robots are just crazy
if they if they think they can run
things off of human brain but whatever
yeah that's true
there are other movies that are getting
closer to this like 13th floor which
i think is decent but
didn't have that visual appeal etc but
and i found it interesting because
stories that your reality isn't real
they are relatively recent certainly
there are a lot of stories where people
are recounting things that turn out to
be dreams which is a good way for the
author to say that okay i'm not actually
not claiming that i actually went to the
moon or that these things happen
but then gradually you get to alice in
wonderland where it's actually being
played around with of course
the author was a logician and was kind
of happy to do recursive stories stories
within stores playing around with the
weird metaphysical possibilities that
happen if you happen to be a dream about
being inside a chess game etc
and gradually we are matured i think
when it comes to storytelling we have
actually learned to accept that stories
within stories or simulated words are
part about the paraphernalia we might
use in
our thinking and i think that is in
itself an interesting part because we
use this kind of images of a future
images of possibilities to reason about
other things when bringing up the risks
of artificial intelligence typically all
of us on the the in that debate groan
whenever somebody brings up the
terminator but it's a standard picture
slowly being nudged out by uh
ava from x marking unfortunately but
it's still kind of these standard
pictures we use for good and ill and i
think
the ability to think that well what if
this was like the matrix or 13th floor
is a useful way of reasoning about many
other things because i do think the
matrix movies got something right many
people feel a weird sense of unreality
there is this unrequited love from the
wachowskis to baudrillard um and
many of us probably feel that when we're
spending our days kind of going through
social media where half of our twitter
followers are probably bought in some
form pretending to be humans for various
nefarious political purposes
speak for yourself anders
i think there is a sense in which the
distinction between self and world is an
empirical fact that is undeniable so in
what sense is that the case well i have
some degree of control over the imagery
in my imagination
but i can't change the world by just
imagining it to be different otherwise
it would be different right now i
promise you
um so there is a sense in which that
distinction is undeniable it's an
empirical datum of existence and then we
can go down the question you know is
this
metaphysically speaking a fundamental
distinction or is this an illusion we
can pursue those paths but i don't think
the core of the problem
is whether there is a subject separate
from us from an object i think the core
of the problem
are the metaphysical assumptions we make
when we talk about a subject when we
talk about a object what do we mean by
these words
um to name two examples
a materialist would deny the distinction
and i would agree with the materialist
there i don't think there is any
fundamental distinction between subject
and object but a materialist would make
that assumption that
the objects the world out there
are exhaustively describable through
quantities in other words if you come up
with the right list of numbers then you
say everything there is to be said about
the object and then because they don't
distinguish the subject from the object
the same has to apply to the subject so
then you face that situation in which my
inner life has to be exhaustively
describable by a list of numbers and i
know for a fact that it isn't because my
inner life is constituted of qualities
not only quantities
now a penn psychist could say well
i will make a a a different assumption i
will say that there are fundamental
boundaries between the subjectivity
inside and the objectivity outside and i
will say that those boundaries are the
boundaries of the primary elements of
the material world whatever they might
be so you're basically saying you're
basically acknowledging the distinction
between object and subject at a
fundamental level
but then you run into another problem
because of one's metaphysical
assumptions and that is well if i have
good reason to think i am fundamentally
separate from the world out there then
by the same token the left hemisphere of
my brain is fundamentally separate from
the right actually by the same token one
neuron is fundamentally separate from
the next neuron one atom from the next
one subatomic particle from the next and
then you have to explain why our inner
lives feel unitary because that's how we
experience it
our inner lives so to summarize and
conclude my answer i don't think the
core of the problem is the question
is the subject distinct from the object
because there is a sense in which it's
obvious obviously is and fundamentally
it probably is not but the problem is
the metaphysical assumptions we make
when we talk about these things
we're used to the idea
that um
in our various endeavors in knowledge in
philosophy and science that there are
deep puzzles
so in philosophy you know there's a
puzzle about uh the nature of
consciousness or there's a puzzle about
the nature of things or of morality or
whatever it being in science there's a
puzzle about what came before the big
bang or what is the structure of force
or
where do we
determine the laws of
the universe
and we usually think of these puzzles as
being somehow problems unexpected
difficulties
and i'd like to suggest you that they're
not they're not surprising at all
our our our models our closures of the
world will always fail
because they're not the same thing as
the stuff out there they're infinitely
different and therefore the closer we
look at them the more we can identify
the bits that don't work
and that's why whatever framework you
have you get problems
that's why wherever you look there are
cracks in the theory
and so the cracks in the in our theories
are not unexpected
gaps
they are inevitable gaps
if we plug the gap in contemporary
science at the moment with um
uh with dark matter and dark energy
there'll be new gaps won't there
there'll be gaps but well how is it
formed uh where do these things really
come from and we imagine that somehow we
can keep on adding and get to the end
but we can't we'll never get to the end
there are always going to be those
puzzles and those puzzles those cracks
are potential for us they're the
potential for us to find another way of
thinking about it a different closure a
different constellation that would
enable us to understand the world in a
way which enable us to achieve things we
can't achieve at the moment
and make hopefully the world a little
bit of a better place
[Music]
ideology is for me
part of our material practices when marx
called but he didn't call it when marx
elaborated the notion of commodity
fatigue
he didn't mean an explicit ideology he
meant
how we actually interact with others
through commodity exchange on the market
ideology is part of our reality so
ideology is not something to be cured of
in the sense of change your mind
especially today in our cynical era
mind
what you think is a mask of what you it
covers up mystifies what you are doing
you are doing in the practice
so how to emancipate ourselves from
ideology to change not so much our mind
but our actual social practice
now
for the young people in this room you
probably can't remember there was a time
when politics was just labor
conservative liberal um in most
countries now it's labour conservative
liberal some nationalisms of the
progressive and reactionary kind and
right-wing populism is the change-maker
is the disrupter marine le pen in france
victor orban in hungary richard tayyip
erdogan in uh
in turkey baltimore in brazil trump in
america and there are others farage here
and when we first saw this um a whole
kind of political science sub-discipline
emerged uh which was about this it's a
pointless game from my point of view how
do we define it define this and then
define fascism against it fine well
there's a european union european
commission has a website devoted to this
problem how do you distinguish between
right-wing populists and fascists and i
buy the the basic definition right-wing
populists don't like democracy they
prefer the will of the people
they don't like human rights at all they
see them as for other people
but they work within democracy and
generally non-violent and their
nationalism is generally cultural
fascists are violent they want to
overthrow democracy
they generally don't attempt to stand
for elections but rather
operate in a space created by by chaos
and their nationalism such as it is will
come to this their nationalism is
primarily ethnic or rather their
prejudices are primarily ethnic and i
can accept that as a description of say
farage here and tommy robinson over
there
the problem is
that
political science also told us and many
political strategies i've met over the
last 30 years have assumed
at least with right-wing populism
obnoxious though it is it's a kind of
firewall against fascism it's a firewall
against the real thing they'll expend
their energies in fruitless demos and
fruitless attempts to win power through
the ballot box because they never win
now these two uh problems are changing
first of all um
right wing populism began to win and
once it had won it began to hollow out
democracy all over the world
with the one objective so that there
could never be any government that was
not right-wing populist this is what
trump did in four years this is what
erdogan has done in turkey what duterte
has done in the philippines um so much
so that political science you know now
has a whole other sub-discipline
studying democratic decay
or what one political scientist called
the franken state
it is very complex and complicated but
we we do have to begin to make sense of
how we unpack that uh because the
reality is that we these those
interlinkages exist yes a lot of them if
i think of you know parts of the
continent of africa that i study a lot
of them are rooted in you know
really horrific colonial experiences but
they continue to exist um but what i
think is most significant is the agency
of those in the former colonized world
the agency they have in how those
resources are utilized so this foreign
investment what purpose does it serve
who decides the purpose that it should
serve um and also making sure of course
the benefits accrue to wider parts of of
society as well
it's very hard to inhabit the psyche of
someone who is
i would argue perhaps irrationally
against the vaccine who will refuse to
you know whether it's kind of like to
use stereotypes hippies in bristol or
people who listen to david eich in
trafalgar square it's very hard to
inhabit their way of thinking but part
of when you were talking about the
practical aspect of needing to vaccinate
a population
for a social prevention of a very real
risk of coronavirus killing people and
what we're also talking about in that
social responsibility is the what are
the risks of can of
limiting and condemning and restricting
people having free opinions that that's
the other side of the risk is what
happens when you mandate something and
what are the ramifications of the risk
that will come with that so it's a you
know i'm really glad you mentioned the
whole thing of talk you know just rely
on the science um which actually is
becoming a trend not just in relation to
covered but in relation to climate
change in relation to uh you know to
bring up that that
word that everyone hates to hear how the
light gets in festival in brexit during
the 2016 referendum the whole idea of
just listen to the experts don't take
risks with the economy or anything there
is this trend to de-politicize issues
and part of the point of risk and our
quality of life our objectives of how we
live because human beings aren't just
about staying alive otherwise we'd be no
better than animals is thinking about
what risks are good what risks are bad
and what risks are worth it you know so
on balance i would always argue that the
risk of you uh taking the vaccine
whatever you conceive that to be is not
worth it to put at risk the other lives
of the rest of your citizens that's
quite sophisticated thing that we have
to try and get people to come along with
the crucial thing is talking about it
having an argument about it rather than
saying because there's a risk you
there's no discussion here that's the
difference between having a very kind of
you know talking about rationality
having a sort of evidence-based um very
a political very kind of site limiting
scientific way of looking at risk and
saying that actually it's part of human
nature to take risk it's part of
politics of democracy to consider risk
i think
assuming that there's sort of an
absolute utopia of free expression
obviously if somebody is in a cinema and
they shout fire that is not something
that is a good thing to do if somebody
is causing harm to other people and
things that they say if they violate
existing laws like with the equalities
act then there has to be serious
consideration around that but the point
i'm trying to make here is that the
state has not been neutral to any of
this this idea of cancer culture being
something that goes from bottom up
instead of top down is a direct um
warping of reality it's not something
that goes from bottom up top down it's
not something that students are doing to
people that get funded by
tory donors
that's not what's happening what's
happening is you have a way in which um
hegemony is established across the
society and that's something that has
played out across the last few decades
in order to carefully establish
parameters of political expression
within the society
[Music]
i was very struck by that that how once
as soon as this result came out um the
uh the the physics um community in the
pre-print server where physicists post
their papers were flooded with
theoretical explanations you know so
many that you you you kind of have to
wonder how how constrained at all is
this problem if so many um
theoretical explanations for something
quite new can seemingly be cooked up
almost overnight um i mean sabine maybe
you can talk to that issue you know do
we really know uh what the problem is
you know is there too much room for
maneuver
yeah so that that's an excellent point
though i have to say as it's often the
case uh if there's a new result coming
out uh there are a lot of people who
already know it's coming so they they
may not have written the papers
overnight and they had some advanced uh
warning but it's certainly true and and
that's exactly what i mean when i say we
have a problem with theory development
when you can explain everything by your
theoretical methods
then
since you were asking you shouldn't pay
any attention to those predictions
they're entirely worthless and that's
what we see that's why they're being
ruled out over and over and over again
because you have all these theories they
literally guess their models because
they like one particular particle or
they like one particular symmetry or
they get obsessed with you know some
anomaly and astrophysics that's
currently on vogue and then the next
year it's gone and so on and so forth
and it just leads nowhere and i i really
think that theoretical physicists they
have to have a hard look at um their
methods of theory development and throw
out what didn't work but the problem is
exactly what uh bjorn
said we have this path dependence
and so we have settled on a particular
method of
making new predictions if you want to
call it that way for new particles which
you can then rule out and that
works very easily if you've learned how
to do it like this is what i was trying
to do basically i know how it works and
that's how you can write papers and
that's how you get grants and that's how
you get your students and then the
students become professors so it just
goes on and on like this and if you want
to do something fundamentally new
you'll have to start over again from
scratch and it becomes very very hard to
find any support
i'm a theoretical physicist and the
world of uh physics
particularly
quantum physics and uh
general relativity theory of gravitation
black holes big bang and so on they're
just full of abstract concepts and so
people really do get the wrong end of
the stick the one that sort of drives me
crazy uh is about the expanding universe
and the big bang
the big bang as far as we know is the
origin of time itself people always want
to say well what happened before the big
bang and the answer is nothing
and then they can't understand how there
can be nothing they think was empty
space but no it's not we're not talking
about empty space we're talking about no
space no time no thing and the expanding
universe people think well what's it
expanding into and the answer again is
nothing the whole universe is expanding
space space is expanding uh maybe the
space is infinite uh it doesn't have to
expand into anything it is space that's
expanding so these things are really
very difficult people have terrible
misconceptions
uh they want to know with the big bang
uh well where did it happen you know was
it over there where's the center of the
universe where it was the edge of the
universe as far as we know there's no
center
and no edge and so these are just
misconceptions it's very very difficult
for
non-physicists
to actually
wrap their heads around these ideas
i'm i'm forever impressed by how how
much mathematics can can make sense of
things and that i don't really
understand but isn't it though that at
the beginning of the universe at least i
guess at the end i've always been told
that
even the mathematics breaks down the
equations break down so they can't
penetrate
beyond that and is that something that
uh is a limitation
this is a really interesting question i
think
one of the first questions we have to
ask is that do we think that mathematics
is an effective language to describe
nature first of all
second of all do we think that
mathematical form logical form exists
independent of a human or other
consciousness to construct it
so both of these questions are i think
relevant in this because
if we talk about scientific
understanding it's very much modeled in
terms of mathematical form
as i said in my introductory pitch
i don't know if in inquiry along these
lines obeying mathematical form will
ultimately lead us to a convergence
about the history and the future of our
universe but i do think it will allow us
to nuance the discussion further and
honestly we have great byproducts as as
we do research in these fields so i
think it's a win personally and i and my
it's my personal choice to continue to
try to answer these questions in this
line of inquiry the second thing about
whether uh mathematics exists
independently of a consciousness
to understand this
well
the next i think this actually raises a
further question for me so we belong to
the universe right we're part of the
universe
can we sit inside the system that we're
trying to understand and truly
assume that we can understand the system
or do we need to construct a language
that's beyond all the languages that
consciousness itself can conceive of to
truly gain a full understanding of the
whole system
that seems like a great point for our
philosopher to jump in and uh put us
right
on this question
i don't want to be on mathematics which
is which is going to give the greater
understanding oh so so i'm i'm
not sure that there's like a
mathematical form that we use right
logical form there are so many different
but there are so many different logics
as well that people employ and play
around with i mean it's not that i think
that we sort of came up with maths and
then were like well let's see if it
works for the universe as a kind of
continuing co-evolution of mathematical
form with the with sort of the language
of physics and theoretical discoveries
in physics and both spur each other on
so i'm not i'm not convinced that maybe
a kind of real paradigm shift in the
kind of logic or maths we use
could lead to
uh further development of our theories
but as you say our theories are doing
extremely well the whole thing we're
discussing here our theories are doing
in a way too well we're really
struggling to find ex
like sort of experimental evidence
that's inconsistent with any of our
theories so i'm not sure why giving up
on sort of logical maths is
going to be motivated by that but on the
kind of point of we need to be outside
the universe to i mean i
i think that's kind of right i think
like the question is time ending the
picture of time ending involves sort of
thinking of being outside time and
watching it end and i'm not sure that's
the kind of thing that we can do but i'm
also not sure how meaningful the
question is so perhaps that's fine that
limitation simplicity is a kind of human
value almost you might say an aesthetic
value right so how do we explain the
fact that it's such a good guide to how
the world outside it there's probably
many explanations one of them it can be
explained in bayesian inference which is
down to thomas bates another cleric of
course but uh yeah he came up with this
uh former statistics now i'll explain it
with two dice
they're invisible dice at the moment
i've got the real ones in my bag but we
won't bother those one dice is as normal
six sided dice the other is a sixty
sided dice and then unseen to you i will
throw one of these dice okay
and the number that comes comes up i
will say is a five
now which dice have i thrown
people will realize of course it's going
to be the six sided dice because there's
only six different numbers it can throw
the 60-sided dice there are 60 different
numbers it can throw that's a smaller
probability smaller probability of
throwing the five
so
this comes out in bayesian reasoning the
likelihood function the likelihood
function is the probability of the data
given the model so the model six sided
dice probability one and six throw in a
five the model 60 sided dice probability
of one in sixty of throne of five
and bayesian reasoning says choose the
simplest because it's the most likely
so for example that was used then in the
same kind of reasoning was used to argue
for by copernicus to argue for
heliocentricity
the model he had
the heliocentric model was no better at
making predictions in the heavens than
ptolemy's model but he argued that it
was simpler
so that argument that it has fewer parts
determined to change so it has a higher
probability of of generating the data if
it inflicts it of course if it doesn't
fit then you've got to have a little
complex model but if your simple model
fits you could should go with that all
of science does that
[Music]
there's there's two questions and it
seems that we're we're fudging the truth
so one is how do we grow pornography and
give people equal access and an equal
authorial voice in pornography now for
me i'm not particularly sold that that
is
a priority and the other question is how
do we increase equality and i do think
you know we need to explore and discover
and and flourish and find ourselves that
is important i'm not 100 convinced that
growing a massive
feminist poor porn industry is the way
to do that in terms of equality this is
a
this is really a distraction and we need
to be careful
we need to be careful because
it's a dangerous distraction because
it's so shiny when you do a film and
there's a sex scene
so often everyone just obsesses about
that sex scene even if it's not
important to the story
and i think this is because it's so
exciting
you know um
and uh
yeah and i think i think this could this
is a bit similar
but my starting point is that there's
nothing wrong with the naked human body
and our genitals
there's also nothing wrong with sex it's
natural and healthy
and if you accept those premises
then surely there could be nothing wrong
with visual depictions
nudity and sex
providing of course
it involves adults and is genuinely
consensual
however
of course we do have to acknowledge that
much of the porn industry is degrading
and humiliating to women and that is so
so wrong
i oppose that just as i oppose the
trafficking coercion of some woman in
the porn industry
we've got to end that we've got to give
those women a way out
but these abuses and they are real
doesn't mean that all porn is ipso facto
automatically and always abusive
as we have heard feminist porn by and
for women
is an attempt to show that porn doesn't
have to be abusive and misogynistic i'm
all for partying i think partying is a
good thing i'm all for pleasure i think
pleasure is a good thing
but we face real challenges as we did in
the 1920s part of the problem of the
1920s
is that
they led to the 1930s a great depression
and a great war
uh what we got from the 1920s is an
unthinking celebration not considering
the long-term consequences of the
actions that are being taken by our
politicians and by our leaders yes party
all you want
but we need to think about the long-term
consequences not of the parties i think
the parties are independent but of the
real challenges that the world faces
i think we live in a very different time
now than the 1920s in a sense i think
they're much more precarious times than
the 1930s
and i think the partying is going to be
quite a bit different i don't see
i don't see
the parties emerging out of uh out of
covert uh the 1920s were a time of great
economic success boom
uh it was a time of great wealth
creation it was a time of incredible
opportunities
and yet we let that again slip into the
great depression today
we're facing low economic growth
we're facing a a a flu that might not go
away a covet that might not go away
we're facing governments that are in
complete disarray
you know afghanistan today is just one
example of the complete incompetence and
disarray of our governments all over the
place we're facing a number of crises
and we've just learned i think over the
last 18 months that our governments are
completely and utterly incompetent in
dealing with the challenges that are
actually before us covert is a great
example of massive government failure
what's there to celebrate
uh that we that we survived well most of
us are young we would have survived no
matter what the government had done uh
the 85 year olds who actually should be
celebrating that they survived
are not going to be the partiers right
uh we should be focusing while
celebrating while having fun just
generally in life
we should really should be focused on
the challenges
on finding ways to restructurize
societies for long-term sustainability
something they didn't do in the 20s and
they suffered in the 1930s as a
consequence
i think that sustainability involves
more freedom
it involves uh limiting our the
government's power to screw up our lives
it involves the ability to seek our
pleasure as individuals
but
that's where the focus and attention
needs to be
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the institute of art
and ideas at iai tv